hey what's up my beautiful people
diavolo here and in today's video we're
going to go over my thoughts on
hanakurasu and what i think her plan and
the jiu jitsu kaizen story may be but
before we get into all of that remember
to subscribe if you're new around here
and leave a like if you enjoy my content
as it really helps out with the
algorithm so one of the two new players
revealed in the last two chapters was
the stunning hannah kadusu who goes by
the name
angel hannah is a young girl with
light-colored eyes and short hair with
bangs that curve inward she wears a
large turtleneck sweater dark pants and
heeled ankle boots she also appears to
have a halo above her head and a pair of
wings on her back
she's confirmed to be a sorcerer from 1
000 years ago which somewhat confirms
the idea of her being around during the
heian era or the golden age of jiu jitsu
sorcery and we know that her ability is
to extinguish people's curse techniques
and i've been thinking about this so it
says in the official translation that
she's a sorcerer from 1 000 years ago
not necessarily 1 000 years or older and
we know that kenjaku has been trying to
form this plan for at least the past 1
000 years
and in my theory about kinjaku i showed
the symbolism between kenjaku and his
similarities with the god of mercy kenon
who was also known by the name
fuku kenjaku now in judo christianity
there is an angel who is often known by
the name ezreal who was tasked by god to
separate the souls
of mortal men from their bodies and he
does not personally know the names of
anyone until a leaf falls from the tree
underneath god's throne bearing the
person's name ezreal was one of god's
most loyal angels because before
the creation of man ezreal proved to be
the only angel brave enough to go down
to earth and face the hordes of ilbus in
order to bring god the materials needed
to make man for the service he was made
the angel of death and given the
register of all mankind he was the
strongest of the four archangels which
also consisted of gibral
mikhail and israel now on my theory here
i think that kinjaku has taken the
position of
the god with his four archangels two of
which we could have possibly even been
shown so far in the series
one being hannah taking the place of
azrael as the angel of death and the
shukugami co-game that each player
receives which acts as an intermediary
or interface between the game master and
each player
is kind of related to the second
archangel gibral the archangel who acts
as an intermediary between god and the
humans as a bearer of revelations to the
prophets for the third and fourth
possible archangel we still haven't had
any characters that could possibly fit
these positions yet uh one could
possibly be the guy that uh sticks with
guido i just can't remember his name
right now this is like a offscript
little addon although hannah does carry
a trumper of some sort that looks
somewhat similar and could be related to
the trumpet of the fourth archangel
israphil who blows the trumpet from the
holy rock of jerusalem to announce the
day of resurrection another thing i was
thinking about in relation to hannah
being the angel of death is the thought
that ezreal after the leaf falls from
the tree he must then separate the body
and soul after 40 days
kind of like those who are marked as
part of the culling game have a total of
19 days to enter the barrier otherwise
they're subject to ct removal which ends
up resulting in death because as we
found out in chapter 146
by the tengen anyone whose curse
techniques that are removed from them
will die but this thought goes off the
idea that it isn't some kind of binding
vowel placed upon anyone marked by
kinjaku's technique it goes off the idea
that kenjaku sends out hanakorusu to
remove the curse techniques of a player
resulting in their death i think this
could also
leave some lead way for yuji and megami
and their role with protecting
sakurami like as instead of her
immediately dying hannah was sent after
sakurami and tries to take away her
ability but say while this is going on
yuda makes a rule after collecting
enough points
so that hannah kadusu must use her
technique on the backdoor of the prison
realm resulting in gojo being freed but
this necessarily wouldn't stop her from
attacking immediately after this is done
and this is just a completely vague and
random idea i came up with after
thinking up this theory
also before i wrap this up i just wanted
to point out something that i saw broku
points out in his video
on hanakurasu during chapter 145 we got
moments that seemed to symbolize some
kind of fate being broken and as we know
with toji now he broke the fate that
connected kenjaku
the tengen and the six eyes when he
received his gifted heavenly
resurrection which completely nullified
or cursed energy that toji possessed
this relates to ezreal with how he is
said to hold a scroll concerning the
fate of mortals i think that the idea of
fate and its prevalence in the series is
going to be brought to the forefront
throughout this final arc the fate that
yuji was sentenced to at the beginning
of the series will be faced along with
finding out the fates of many people
like nabarro that we still aren't 100
sure of
anyway this is all i could think of at
the time and i'd love to hear what you
all think so make sure to leave a
comment down below with what your
predictions are for
hinakurusu and the up and coming
chapters also remember to
leave a like if you've enjoyed my video
and subscribe to become a part of
jujutsu high
and uh keep up to date with the latest
jjk news but for now it's been a
professional degenerate dear follow and
i'll see you guys in a bit
bye
[Music]
you